Now, let's dig a little deeper into the power of abstraction as it applies to
computer systems. Now, here I'm showing you
a screenshot of the Google Earth application. Deep
down in the silicon, you have electrons
and holes. You may have heard about these
terminologies or worked with them in a physics 101 course at some point of time.
Let's say that in an application such as Google Earth, you move your mouse
from Atlanta, Georgia to Chennai, India. When you do that, magic
happens on the screen. Now, between a user action,
such as moving the mouse from Atlanta, Georgia to Chennai,
India, and the solid state electronics that
is enshrined in your computer system, there is a whole series of abstractions.